clayton kershaw's from nearby highland
park texas his lowest era
since 2016. that's the fifth best dra in
the national league
coming off a wild card performance where
he struck out 13
over eight shutout innings first pitch
of this one
is popped up by tatis left side of the
infield corey seeger
has it and one pitch one out
and then gets a fastball by him at 93
which is not something you saw clayton
kershaw do in the last couple years
kicks and fires one two osmer bangs one
into the ground and at first
muncie will take it to the bag to finish
a one two three first inning for kershaw
zach davies who is second in the
national league and wins he was fifth in
era and
probably most importantly given all the
circumstances here
he pitched into the sixth inning in ten
of his twelfth strikes
secret pulls it sharply goes the second
one and tatis throws it wide
seeger's aboard on the fielder's choice
[Applause]
he's down swinging here on a chain jump
there he goes here it comes
he grabs it to first for eric hosmer
both pitchers put up zeroes in the first
inning
lead man aboard here for tommy pham
having a nice post season
so kershaw not it's a good matchup for
the boys lined in the right center field
nobody's catching that off the battle
will myers he goes awful to right center
field here comes tommy pham
hoppy's going to bring him home the
relay the throw comes up the third
baseline backing up is kershaw
as it goes past austin barnes and my
padres have a one to nothing lead in the
time of the second
he's got a fight in this in this setback
kershaw gets him to chase for out number
one
the one-two breaking ball swung on and
missed strike three
the curve ball at 74. they've got a
corner with nobody out eight and nine in
the order with back-to-back singles
open the third here we go though first
and third nobody out he swings to the
first pitch in a liner caught it
third base by manny machado diving
towards the line he's able to make the
play and betts is out
one down in the third on a rocket shot
off the bat of the 2018 american league
mvp
first and third for seeger here's his
two one
sega pulls it down though and a fair
ball and he won't get out of it
ricochets off that angled sidewall
pollock into score barnes headed for the
play the thrill goes into second
and the dodgers take a 2-1 lead sega's
in second
two gone here's muncie foxy muscles
running to right center field that'll
sink in for a base hit and score seeger
the dodgers with a three spot here in
the third
cody bellinger swings at the first pitch
at the end he launches about a center
field
into the first pitch of the fourth he
leaves the yard
first home run of this series comes from
the reigning mvp
and the dodgers have a 4-1 lead
a dozen home runs during the regular
season he's now
4 for 12 in the postseason
long-haired dallas texas native
looking in and dealing and golfs down
that
uh change up in the left field got a
shot car rushed
deep left field ball going for manny
machado
not even an a swing like a b minor
semi-fool going down to get that ball
and now you got a ball game
4-2-4-2 very much a ball game
and this one is hit well by haas in
their right field
way deep in right field car rushed
by going by god eric hosper who's the
best hitter against kershaw in the ball
club
eric hosmer that's who and a home run
and a one-run ball game
in game two sixth inning long way from
over
here come them boys we saw a hundred
already
this is ball to deep center field
ballinger twisting around
still going he's at the wall
cody bellinger robs tatis of a two-run
home run
his glove was six or seven inches over
the yellow line and straight away center
a spectacular catch by
cody bellinger and the dodgers get out
of the inning
oh what a play dude he throws the glove
and then blows the kiss over to manny
machado who didn't like him throwing the
glove
and he says you you
tempers flaring between two teams that
they're very emotionally charged games
during the regular season
it's the dodgers putting themselves in a
great spot to expand the lead turner
corks one to center field the line hits
christian it's plenty deep enough to
bring home betts from third and the
dodgers lead five
through for the base hit
beating the shift here's a little
teardrop shuttle left profile
sprint won't get there it falls in front
of him and seeger's into score
[Music]
got the final two outs of game one
needed just nine pitches to do that
here he is looking for the save in game
two as will myers leads it
off for the padres good start for jensen
as he strikes out myers
on a 3-2 pitch cronin worth runs
moreland
swings and drives the ball to the gap
and right center field that'll split
them and get up against the wall
mitch moreland with a pinch hit rbi
double
and san diego brings the tying run up at
the 9.
3-2 towards right-center field and
they'll get tatties junior to the plate
of the ninth inning
fbi single trent grisham it's 6'5
and up comes tatis
it'll be against joe kelly and now one
of the best
rbi guys in baseball in postseason
eric hosmer
brown ball to second hernandez has it on
the first
and that's it the dodgers escaped
6-5 the final score to take a 2-0 series
advantage
what a game